حسنًا ، من الرائع الترحيب بعودة
رئيس الوزراء ، لقد كنا أصدقاء حميمين
لفترة من
الوقت ، ولكن من الجيد أن يكون هنا في
البيت الأبيض ، فقد عقدنا الكثير من
الاجتماعات في جميع أنحاء البلاد حول
العالم
الذي كنا معه  بعضنا البعض ، ما يقرب من نصف
دزينة من المرات حتى الآن كان
عامًا مزدحمًا ،
وأه تعلم
أننا نعلم أننا نبقي أذهاننا على
مقربة من العائلات المتضررة
من العواصف التي غمرت أه
في منطقة كولومبيا البريطانية ومنطقة
شمال غرب المحيط الهادئ ولكن واحدة من  الأشياء التي
أمضينا وقتًا فيها
مدرجة في جدول أعمالنا العالمي هي تغير
المناخ ، لقد أمضينا الكثير من الوقت في التعامل
مع ذلك ونحن على نفس الصفحة فيما
يتعلق بحاجتنا إلى المضي قدمًا
والحصول على بقية  العالم يتحرك
، ومنذ اجتماعنا الثنائي
الأول في فبراير
، التقينا وأماكن حول العالم
تحت السيطرة 19 في محاولة
للتعامل مع الوباء التالي الذي
أعددناه له
بالإضافة إلى تلبية احتياجات البنية التحتية في
جميع أنحاء العالم النامي ، نرى
الفرصة
ليس فقط ر  o عزز احتمالات
حياة أفضل للناس في جميع أنحاء
العالم وهم القيم الأساسية للكنديين
والولايات المتحدة ، لذا
فهذه واحدة من أسهل العلاقات
التي يمكن أن تحظى بها كرئيس أمريكي وهي
واحدة من أفضل العلاقات التي
نرحب بها ،
شكرًا لك السيد  الرئيس أه شكرا جو
إنه أه لقد كانت سنة مزدحمة
أه يسعدني أن أعود إلى هنا في
واشنطن معك ولكن كما تقول
لقد كان لدينا أه البيلات الافتراضية ، فقد واجهنا
العديد من اللقاءات من جميع الأنواع
المختلفة أه دولية  منتديات حيث
كنا متفقين بشدة مع
البيئة على أه مكافحة كوفيد
والحصول على أه تجاوز هذا الوباء
استعدادا
لتحديات المستقبل